This hanging mass is made entirely of bees.
The swarm can hold itself together
even when shaken about by the wind.
Now a team of scientists have been finding out how.
About once a year, colonies of honeybees leave their nests in swarms
searching for a new home.
Until they find a new site the bees rest
in these temporary clusters.
The clusters are often found in trees
but this one is forming in a lab
at Harvard in Massachusetts.
little do the bees know they're about to go for a ride.
The researchers built this shaking apparatus
to investigate how the bee swarm reacts to movement.
When shaken from side to side,
shearing forces act on the colony,
with the bees at the top taking the brunt of it,
as they try to hold up everything beneath them.
The forces threaten to destabilize the whole colony.
So the bees do something clever
they spread out.
The flatter shape changes the colony's centre of mass,
and so it wobbles less
reducing the pressure on the bees.
It makes sense,
imagine you're standing up and you
find the ground shaking beneath you
instinctively you'd crouch down, same principle.
Anyway, what's particularly interesting here
is that the forces at play are
acting on the swarm as a whole,
but each bee can't see the shape of the swarm -
so how does it know where to go or what to do?
To find out researchers tracked
the bees on the outside of the swarm.
As the colony shook they moved upwards
to where the stress is greatest.
The researchers modelled this behaviour
and found that if all the bees follow the rule
- move towards the area of higher stress -
the colony flattens out,
increasing its stability
and so decreasing the average stress on each bee.
Great for the colony
but individual bees are actively putting
themselves under more stress to do it.
This kind of altruistic behaviour
is not very common in nature
except, that is, in eusocial insects like bees and ants
which rely on altruism for survival.
What's more
even though each individual bee
doesn't necessarily know what's going on,
by simply moving towards an area of higher stress
the colony as a whole acts intelligently.
This is called emergent intelligence
and some scientists think that
it's through a process like this
that individual neurons firing in our brain
can collectively come together to make, well
us.
Talk about a hive mind